Toyota knows how to make cars.
It does it so well it became the first company...
...to produce more than 10 million a year.
Its success is rooted in a special system...
...and began what is now known as "Lean Manufacturing",...
...an ethos emulated by companies around the world...
...to make products faster, cheaper and better.
Here's how Toyota changed the way we make things.
Cousin Eiji would travel to the U.S....
...with a veteran loom machinist, Taiichi Ohno.
They visited Ford's River Rouge plant in Michigan...
...and were impressed by the scale of the operation.
But knew that in cash-strapped Japan companies...
...didn't have the resources for such a system.
Having months worth of stock sitting in a warehouse...
...would tie up precious capital they didn't have.
Instead, what truly impressed Ohno was a visit to a supermarket,...
...a Piggly Wiggly according to legend.
Japan didn't really have self-service stores at this point...
...and he was struck by the way customers...
...could choose exactly what they wanted, when they wanted.
He decided to model his production line on a similar idea.
With the supermarket formula, only enough parts...
...were produced in the first phase...
...to replace what was used in the 2nd and so on.
This is where the "Just in Time" system really took shape.
Toyota was able to eliminate much of the waste in Ford's system,...
...making smaller numbers of parts to be used when it needed them,...
...allowing the company to operate on a tighter budget.
As part of this Ohno developed "Kanban"...
... a sign based scheduling method which shows goods in,...
...goods in production, and goods out.
It's now seen as a precursor to bar codes.
Ohno and Toyoda also noticed that American car companies...
...were still employing many of Henry Ford's early production techniques.